put
a barrier to
neo-nazis and
extreme nationalists
because what is happening at in other
territories is the confirmation to that
the people
living in donbass also did not
agree to this
coup
against them
a punishing operations
was started
they were shelled
by
guns and aviation this is all that is
called genocide
and to read people of this suffering and
genocide is
the main reason and purpose of our
military operation which we started in
donbass and ukraine this is exactly our
purpose so
i have
remember the words from the
saint
book there is
no more love
more than
if someone gives a soul for their
friends
for his friends
and we can see that heroically
our guys
fight in during this operation
[Applause]
[Music]
from the sacred
book of christianity from
have faith in this religion
but this is a universal value for all
the peoples and all the religions in
russia and especially for our people
and to the best confirmation is the fact
how
our guys are fighting during this
operation shoulder to shoulder they
support each other
if needed
they cover
with their own body
cover in the battlefield we haven't had
this unity for a long time
it happened so that the beginning of
this operation
accidentally incident coincided
see
to rid people of suffering and genocide
that was the reason
we just heard from vladimir putin he
said for
the military operations as he put it in
donbass in ukraine he went on to refer
to religious texts saying he was quoting
from as he put it the sacred book of
christianity saying there is no greater
love than to give your soul for your
friend
that is of course
going on at a concert which has been
called to mark the day when crime when
russia
integrated crimea into the russian
federation
which came of course after the
occupation of crimea
a move that is being commemorated right
now by this concert
in ukraine it's coming of course in
russia rather but it's coming at the
same time as the war is going on
in ukraine which makes an event like
this of course even more
important for vladimir putin